إذا أدرت كرة حول محور واحد ثم حول محور آخر، فهذا ليس نفس فعل الدورانين بالترتيب العكسي
اليوم في Qiskit في الفصل سنرى ما علاقة هذه الكرة بالحواسيب الكمية وأحد أشهر
مبادئ ميكانيكا الكم: مبدأ عدم اليقين
مرحباً بكم في Qiskit في الفصل، سلسلة فيديو نشرح فيها مفهوماً أساسياً قد
تصادفه في دورة متعلقة بالحوسبة الكمية. كل فيديو مصحوب بوحدة تفاعلية مرتبطة في
الوصف أدناه فتأكد من الاطلاع عليها. اليوم نتحدث عن مبدأ عدم اليقين لـ Heisenberg. إذا
سمعت عنه من قبل فربما سمعت أيضاً النكتة القديمة عن Heisenberg. ذات يوم أوقفه شرطي أثناء القيادة وسأله هل
تعرف كم كانت سرعتك؟ فأجاب Heisenberg: لا، لكنني أعرف بالضبط أين أنا. هذا تقريباً
مبدأ عدم اليقين لـ Heisenberg باختصار. لا يمكنك معرفة موقع الجسيم وكمية حركته في آنٍ واحد
بدقة مثالية. يُكتب عادة هكذا: دلتا x ضرب دلتا p أكبر من
أو يساوي h/2 حيث دلتا X ودلتا P هما
عدم اليقين في الموقع وكمية الحركة وh هو ثابت أساسي صغير جداً في ميكانيكا الكم
توصل Heisenberg إلى هذه المتراجحة عام 1927 عندما كان يتخيل كيفية قياس موقع إلكترون. إذا
ارتد فوتون عنه لترى أين هو، فإن ذلك الفوتون سيركل الإلكترون حتماً ويزعج كمية
حركته. هذا ليس مجرد تصريح عن القياسات التي تزعج النظام بل يخبرنا أن هناك حدوداً أساسية
لما يمكننا تعلمه عن الطبيعة. هذا مثال واحد على مبدأ أوسع يُسمى التكامل والذي
يقول إن جوانب معينة من الطبيعة غير متوافقة مع بعضها ولا يمكن ملاحظتها
في آنٍ واحد. مثلاً، الأجسام الكمية أحياناً تتصرف كجسيمات وأحياناً كموجات
لكن لا يمكنك ملاحظة كلا السلوكين في آنٍ واحد. علاقة Heisenberg للموقع وكمية الحركة تغطي مجموعة واحدة فقط من
العديد من مجموعات السمات التكاملية. هذا عدم اليقين المتأصل له علاقة بكيفية رؤيتنا لخاصية مثل
الموقع وكمية الحركة في ميكانيكا الكم. بدلاً من التفكير في X وP كمتغيرات أو خصائص متأصلة
يمتلكها كل جسيم، في ميكانيكا الكم الموقع وكمية الحركة مؤثرات. ليست خصائص لنظام
بل أشياء يمكنك فعلها بالنظام. معرفة موقع جسيم الآن تتطلب منك إجراء
عملية على ذلك النظام وإجراء قياس. هذه العملية قد تؤثر على نتيجة عمليات
لاحقة أخرى. كتشبيه فكر في قطعة خشب جافة. لها عدة خصائص مثل
موقعها وحجمها وشكلها. لها أيضاً خاصية القابلية للاحتراق والقابلية للطفو في الماء. إذا كانت هذه الخشبة جسماً
كمياً، فهذه لن تكون خصائص تعرفها مسبقاً. بدلاً من ذلك نقول إنها
ملاحظات: أشياء يمكنك معرفتها عن النظام إذا أجريت عملية ما عليه. فستحتاج لتطبيق مؤثر
القابلية للاحتراق أو القابلية للطفو مما يتطلب فعلياً محاولة حرق الخشب أو وضعه في
الماء لترى إن كان يطفو. الآن نتيجة كل من هذين المؤثرين تعتمد على ترتيب تطبيقهما. إذا
اختبرت القابلية للاحتراق أولاً فالخشب سيحترق إلى رماد ولن تتمكن من اختبار إن كان يطفو. لكن إذا اختبرت
القابلية للطفو أولاً فسيكون مبللاً جداً ليحترق. نقول إن مؤثري القابلية للاحتراق
والقابلية للطفو لا يتبادلان. ترتيب العمليات مهم. هذا يؤدي إلى حد أساسي
لمدى معرفتنا بهاتين الملاحظتين عن قطعة الخشب لأننا لا نستطيع الجزم إن كانت
قابلة للاحتراق أو للطفو بدون معرفة سياق ذلك القياس. الآن بالطبع مع قطعة خشب حقيقية يمكنك
قطعها نصفين واختبار كلتا الخاصيتين في آنٍ واحد. لكن لا يمكنك فعل شيء كهذا مع جسيم كمي. هذا
التشبيه بالخشب هو مجرد تشبيه. عدم اليقين شيء كمي فريد. X وP أيضاً لا يتبادلان
وهذه خاصية عدم التبادل هي ما يؤدي إلى مبدأ عدم اليقين لـ Heisenberg. بشكل عام أي مؤثرين
لا يتبادلان سيكون لهما مبدأ عدم يقين خاص بهما. الشكل العام لمبدأ عدم اليقين يمكن
كتابته هكذا: دلتا A ضرب دلتا
B أكبر من أو يساوي
1/2 ضرب A وB حيث
هذا القوس يُسمى
المبدّل وهو يساوي الفرق بين تطبيق A أولاً ثم
B وتطبيق B أولاً ثم A. هذه الأقواس الزاوية
هنا تعني أنك تأخذ ما يُسمى القيمة المتوقعة لما بداخلها. أساساً إذا أجريت نفس
القياس مرات عديدة جداً فإن القيمة المتوقعة هي متوسط كل تلك القياسات. اليوم سنقوم
فعلاً باختبار والتحقق من مبدأ عدم اليقين هذا على حاسوب IBM الكمي. سننظر إلى ثلاث
ملاحظات مختلفة لـ qubit ونبيّن أن مؤثراتها لا تتبادل وبعد ذلك سنتمكن من إثبات أن
مبدأ عدم اليقين ينطبق على ملاحظات الـ qubit هذه. أولاً ملاحظة جانبية سريعة عن طريقة مفيدة لتصور الحالة
الكمية لـ qubit. يمكن تمثيلها بمتجه يشير إلى مكان ما على كرة تُسمى كرة Bloch. غطيت
هذا في فيديو سابق مرتبط في الوصف لكنني سأعطيكم ملخصاً سريعاً هنا أيضاً. هذه
كرة Bloch. كل متجه يُعلمن بزاويتين Theta وPhi
الحالة صفر على القطب الشمالي والحالة واحد على القطب الجنوبي وتراكب متساوٍ من 0 و1
يكون في مكان ما على خط الاستواء حيث Phi يساوي الطور النسبي بين جزأي
التراكب. إذن هذه الحالة هنا ستساوي
1/جذر 2 ضرب 0 زائد e أُس i Phi ضرب 1 حيث i هو ذلك
الطور. عندما نقيس ملاحظة لـ qubit تكون النتيجة دائماً واحدة من خيارين يقابلان الحالتين
المحتملتين للـ qubit. للتجربة التي سنجريها سننظر إلى ثلاث ملاحظات
ومؤثراتها المقابلة X وY وZ. عندما تقيس أياً من هذه الملاحظات تحصل إما على زائد واحد أو
ناقص واحد باحتمال لكل منهما يعتمد على الزاوية بين متجه الـ qubit على كرة Bloch و
محور القياس. كما قد تتوقع، Z يقيس على طول محور Z وX على طول X
وY على طول Y. الآن تذكر أننا نتحدث عن ملاحظات لأنه مع نظام
كمي لم يعد بإمكاننا ببساطة معرفة أشياء عن النظام بدون قياسها
وكل ملاحظة لها عملية مقابلة لأن القياسات تتطلب عمليات. قد لا يكون واضحاً لكن
اتضح أن العمليات المسماة مؤثرات التي تقابل كل من هذه الملاحظات x وy وz هي
دورانات بمقدار باي حول محاورها المعنية. فـ X هو دوران حول X وY
حول Y وZ حول Z. لنرى إن كانت هذه المؤثرات تتبادل أم لا يمكننا التحقق مما إذا كانت الدورانات
على كرة تتبادل. إذا تبادلت فإن مبدأ عدم اليقين لن ينطبق وسنتمكن من معرفة X وY وZ عن qubit
بدقة مثالية. إذا لم تتبادل فسنتمكن من إيجاد علاقة عدم يقين جديدة للـ qubit. شاهد
النقطة على هذه الكرة وأنا أدور أولاً حول X ثم حول Y. تنتهي
هنا. الآن دعونا نجرب بالترتيب العكسي فأدور أولاً حول Y ثم
حول X. تنتهي هنا. إذن هي بالتأكيد لا تتبادل. هذا يعني
أننا لا نستطيع معرفة قيم X وY وZ الدقيقة للـ qubit في آنٍ واحد وسيكون لدينا
علاقة عدم يقين. سنتخطى التفاصيل هنا لكن ننتهي بثلاث علاقات عدم يقين
مختلفة. لدينا دلتا X ضرب دلتا Y
أكبر من أو يساوي Z ودلتا Y ضرب دلتا Z أكبر من أو
يساوي X ودلتا Z ضرب دلتا X أكبر من أو يساوي
Y. إذن حاصل ضرب أي اثنين من حالات عدم اليقين هذه دائماً أكبر من أو
يساوي القيمة المتوقعة للملاحظة الثالثة. دعونا نستخدم Qiskit لنرى ما
يحدث عندما نحاول قياس كل من Z وX للحالة صفر. قياس Z سهل فهو ما يُسمى الأساس المعياري
للحاسوب الكمي. القياسات تكون دائماً على طول Z بشكل افتراضي. لكن لقياس X نحتاج لإجراء ما يُسمى
تغيير أساس وهو أساساً تدوير كرة Bloch بحيث يشير X الآن للأعلى حيث كان Z يشير. لفعل ذلك
نستخدم gate Hadamard. إذن الـ circuit الكمي الكامل سيبدو هكذا: نقيس في Z ونطبق Hadamard
ثم نقيس في X. إذا استخدمنا بدائية العيّنات في Qiskit لتشغيل هذه التجربة عدة مرات ننتهي
بمدرج تكراري لنتائج القياس يبدو هكذا لقياس
Z وهكذا للقياس في X. كما ترى قسنا
الـ qubit في الحالة صفر على طول Z بنسبة قريبة من 100% يقين. لكن
على طول X لم نكن نعرف شيئاً تقريباً عن حالة الـ qubit. تم قياسه إما صفر أو واحد باحتمال
متساوٍ مما يعني أن عدم يقيننا في X كان كبيراً قدر الإمكان. هذا يعطينا
إحساساً بهذه المقايضة في عدم اليقين. لكن يمكننا عمل ما هو أفضل. على حاسوبنا الكمي يمكننا استخدام
بدائية Qiskit المسماة المُقدِّر لإيجاد القيم المتوقعة لملاحظاتنا X وY وZ و
عدم اليقين في كل منها. دعونا نجربها للحالة التي تشير في اتجاه X الموجب على كرة Bloch. سنستخدم المُقدِّر
لحساب عدم اليقين في X وZ لهذه الحالة والقيمة المتوقعة
لـ Y. مع هذه الحالة نحصل على هذه النتيجة من Qiskit. عندما نأخذ حاصل ضرب
عدم اليقين في X وY نرى أنه كما هو متوقع أكبر من القيمة المطلقة
للقيمة المتوقعة لـ Y. لكن هذا كان لحالة واحدة فقط. نريد التأكد من أن هذه المتراجحة
صحيحة لجميع حالات الـ qubit. إذن دعونا نستخدم المُقدِّر مرة أخرى لكن هذه المرة سنطلب منه المسح عبر قيم
معامل وإيجاد القيم المتوقعة عند كل قيمة معامل نعطيها. هنا المعامل الذي نريد
مسحه هو الزاوية Theta على كرة Bloch بحيث نتحقق من المتراجحة لجميع حالات الـ qubit التي تقع على
هذا القوس الذي يتقاطع مع مستوى XZ. عندما نفعل ذلك نحصل على رسم بياني كدالة للزاوية Theta. المنحنى
الأحمر هو حاصل ضرب عدمي اليقين والمنحنى البرتقالي هو القيمة المتوقعة لـ Y. كما هو متوقع
حاصل ضرب عدم اليقين في X وZ أعلى بكثير من القيمة المتوقعة لـ Y. لكن لم يكن
من الصعب جداً تحقيق المتراجحة لأن القيمة المتوقعة لـ Y كانت منخفضة جداً وكانت صفراً لجميع الحالات على
هذا القوس. دعونا نجري مسحاً مشابهاً عبر قيم Theta لكن بدلاً من المسح في مستوى XZ سنضع Phi يساوي باي/
4 بحيث ننظر إلى حالات الـ qubit التي تقع على قوس مختلف على الكرة. هنا نرى أن المتراجحة
تُختبر أكثر بما أن المنحنى البرتقالي والأحمر أقرب لبعضهما. لكن الأحمر دائماً فوق البرتقالي
ومبدأ عدم اليقين لا يزال صامداً. لم نتحقق من جميع الحالات بعد لكن نأمل أنكم بدأتم تستوعبون
الفكرة. هناك عدم قابلية معرفة أساسية حول أي جانبين تكامليين من نظام
كمي بما في ذلك هذا الـ qubit الذي كنا نستخدمه. مبدأ عدم اليقين يجبرنا على مواجهة حقيقة أنه مهما
حاولنا جاهدين ومهما كانت قياساتنا ذكية لن نعرف كل شيء بدقة مثالية أبداً.
لا مفر من ذلك حقاً. إذا لم تصدقني أو حتى إن صدقتني أتحداك اذهب واطلع على الوحدة
المرتبطة في الوصف وحاول أن تتغلب على مبدأ عدم اليقين. شكراً للمشاهدة وأراكم في المرة القادمة.